[Music]
[Applause]
boston is a three and a half point
favorite tonight game three as we make
way for the hall of famer reggie miller
uh let's go back to the end of game two
i didn't get a text from you after the
golden state warriors one i got one
after game one it was like told you
oh no see you're reading way
more into that i just simply gave you a
text saying this is going to be a long
series like told you like i picked when
did i say it wasn't going to be a long
series no you wanted to spell
because you and riker were all in with
golden state and rightfully so i want
gold i want stephen curry to win
get his fourth
get the finals mvp which he's on track
to do
and enter we talked about entering a
different door
in terms of the great players he would
be a part of that
but i just felt the way boston has been
playing
that
that's why i was going to watch no no
you told me what it was gonna i never
said it wasn't gonna be a long series i
never said that i just said i picked
golden state at the beginning of the
year reggie not at the start of the nba
finals
that's not my job to pick who's gonna
that's your job no that's your job
you're an analyst i'm an analyst i'm not
no that's like playing favorites i don't
play favorites i call it like i see it
and i was just assessing both teams at
this particular time and what austin has
done to get to the nba finals going
through brooklyn going through the
champs milwaukee going through miami i
just think the momentum has kind of
shifted towards them and that's not to
discredit anything golden state has done
because they've been great
i'm just looking at it
it just felt like i i told you that's
all like i didn't hear it
how do you like this name since you're
talking about meats reginald aloysius
mutton
that's my new name
reginald aloysius mutton so if we had a
meat name you would be we had a meat
name
mutton
mutton uh fritzy what's yours
i was gonna be toddy salami toddy's
i like reginald aloysius mutton better
okay what do you expect to happen
tonight in boston what's interesting
is as a former player
when the series is tied 1-1 game three
and when a series is tied 2-2 game 5 are
always the most interesting because you
pretty much know what each team is going
to do obviously there'll be wrinkles
there'll be adjustments but you pretty
much have a game plan of how both teams
were playing and the one thing that will
always stand out in this
series and you hear both coaches
preaching this which team can be
more physical the physicality and it's
interesting how
you know you hear the whole draymond
green cedric maxwell the 80s 90s today's
basketball the way the game is
officiated during their regular season
they want freedom of movement
touch fouls
a lot of replay
and when we get to the playoffs it
reverts back to the 80s and 90s the
officials don't want to be responsible
for
all these calls they make it much more
physical so it's funny how during the
regular season
they let these guys run around shoot
threes and all that come play off time
there's more holding there's more
hitting
it's much more physical so whatever team
can be more physical it was golden
state's turn to hit first and that's
what they did in game two
to even up this series to me going
forward which team can be more
physical consist consistently well and
i'm i'm listening to draymond he's a
student of the game but when he talks
about you know oh they talk about how
physical it was back in the day and the
thing is is
they were physical with the best players
the greatest player
was roughed up more than anybody and
michael jordan with the pistons they
allowed that to happen they would never
let that happen now they would never let
you beat up on luca they would never let
you beat up on the greek freak they
would stop it immediately so when
draymond talks about that
yes there are a couple of enforcers but
there were a lot of guys on the
receiving end of those enforcers and
that's what that's what i think he's got
wrong draymond would have been great
back in the 80s and 90s yes yes he would
um
because he is a
let's face it
he talks to talk but he walks it as well
and he's not afraid to put his body on
the line and he's not afraid to
challenge his teammates as well as the
opponents
but
it's hard to compare eras because
there's different rules from the 80s the
90s and obviously the 2000s so
i understand where he's coming from
um but i will say this i i know he was
kind of taking shots at cedric maxwell
cedric maxwell was a baller back in the
day and i don't think he's giving
cedric
enough uh
credit on his type of game because just
be you know saying that he would have
been bullied
no that's not the case because cedric
maxwell
he
could talk to talk and walk it as well
so i think he needs to do a little
history you're right he he's a historian
but he needs to know that
that central could bring that he could
bring the heat too all right a complete
non-sequitur well it kind of fits in a
little bit here but i had a caller
saying
um
you got ben wallace in the hall of fame
why isn't bill lane beer and i said you
have a valid point because bill lane
beer is a better player they both made
the all-star team four times ben was a
great off-the-ball defender but he
didn't he didn't offer anything else
you know maybe rebounding but if i said
you could have bill lane beer or ben
wallace
as a teammate
uh
in the 80s 90s or or in today's
basketball because that matters
uh because bill
bill lambie
very good back then
he could pick and pop which is in today
you know big men are supposed to be are
required to be able to shoot threes now
right so bill lambert would be great in
today's game he was great in the 80s and
late early 90s
but didn't ben wallace win uh defensive
player of the year three or four times
yeah i don't think bill lambert ever did
that no but bill was a far better player
than ben wallace he was a more skilled
player but before that i i
in my book i would put robert orry
in the hall of fame before bill lambert
in my opinion
i would put big shot bob a book before
building a beer
i would like to know total points
between bill lambert and robert ore
if paulie if you can look that up didn't
robert orry average like eight points a
game maybe for his career
maybe
but how many big shots well he did he
hit big shots but you know why he was
open because he had teammates who were
double-teamed
he hit the shot
i'm not saying bill lambert shouldn't be
in the hall of fame but i'm just saying
there's other guys that
probably could move ahead of him paulie
what what did ory average uh well okay
total points a bill lambeau played
15 seasons and scored just under 14 000
points robert dorey played
i think 17 season 16 seasons and only
scored 7 700 points
half
yeah
robert rory shouldn't be in the
[Laughter]
hey hit some big shots red
it's a big shot
bill lane beer
is just not light and i'm sure that
jordan would throw a fit if bill name
beer went into the hall of fame but
that's not right
i hated bill lambert just as much as
jordan
but
i bet you jordan would have wished he
could have played with bill lambert who
did you hate the most out of the pistons
who did i hate the worst yeah
probably
probably my horn
i wasn't really worried about lambear
um
because you know that clip of
robert parish
beating down bill lambert in the garden
yeah
we had a center steve stepanovich yeah
from missouri out of missouri yeah who
did the same thing
so i was never worried about bill and
beer because i know we had stephen
but it was my horn man mchorn had a
crazy like
a crazy look in his eye all the time
and what's funny is
because i think i've told this story
before joe dumas
the gentle bad boy
would always tell me reg i'm just
telling you if you always say
if you beat me off the dribble and get
by me
just be careful because your
horn is going to take you out
get out of here get out of here about
his own teammate you know that the guy's
a bad dude he's calling out his own he's
wrapping out his own teammate don't do
it reg
sure enough
blow by him
and damn here missing a tooth
damn near
yes so
it was more horn i was more worried
about as opposed to bill them here
though i mean bill
lambie took shots as well but horn was
he was a little different
i'm wondering if we're
not overrating but over expecting from
jason tatum i know he's first-team
all-nba
but
are we expecting too much out of him on
this big stage for him to be
a a truly great player
i think he's i think he's
ascending to being a great player i
don't think he's a great player yet
well i i think people look at his resume
on what he did versus kevin durant in
the first round
what he did against giannis
in the semifinals and how he performed
at the highest stage versus jimmy butler
in the culture of miami so i think it's
fair and valid that we put him on that
pedestal you mentioned it he's first
team all-nba
and i know he's what 24 25 years old and
that is a lot of weight to carry
and especially on a storied franchise
like boston who are known to have great
small forwards like larry legend and
paul pierce
and cedric maxwell as well so
it's a lot
to carry for a young player but i think
he's willing
to accept that um if he didn't have
that kind of series versus kevin durant
where they swept them i think people
wouldn't put him on that pedestal
because let's face it he outplayed kd
who's a lot of people consider the best
player in today's game right now he
outplayed them i played them for four
games i think that's why we look at him
a little bit different
talking to reggie miller the hall of
famer what's the fundraiser you're doing
the uh ranch rally coming up saturday
i'm gonna be on my bike a long time 75
miles in steamboat springs colorado it's
going to raise money for two charities
really it's moots who is my
gravel bike carrier um and maker
for the agricultural for the farmers
there in steamboat but they're also
raising funds for hbcus to get more
diversity inclusion
uh in cycling that's been my big
initiative since i've been cycling is to
get more people
um
you know more women
more asians uh more indigenous everyone
i want more people on bikes um
i didn't grow up in the cycling world
cycling can somewhat be expensive but
every kid should have the opportunity to
have a bike and cycle and that's what
we're kind of raising funds for in
colorado so i'm taking the show on the
road it's going to be a great 75 miles
on beautiful gravel roads in steamboat
colorado so i'm really looking forward
to it how would you do in the tour de
france
oh my god i would get destroyed here's
the thing those are stage races so
that's like 21 days straight i think
there's two off days in between there's
just no way because i would be dead
after the first day how can they ride
100 miles basically every day for 21
straight days i i just it's
it's hard to even think about it
i remember
lance armstrong said that he got on his
bike one time and he just kept writing
and then he realized he was a hundred
miles away
he goes then you have to turn around and
go back and he's like yeah i know go
back i mean i don't understand how these
dudes do it it's
look i i love cycling i love what it's
done for me post retirement um
but some of these dudes and girls are
crazy like they just had a race in
kansas called unbound gravel and it's a
200 mile gravel race i don't understand
how you can ride 200 miles and function
after that but they do do you have a
bell on your bike i do and i let people
know when i'm coming up
on your left
on your left but the sad thing about it
is everyone else has bell and i hear
that all the time because i'm one of the
slower ones
i hear bells all the time and it's i was
just in a race in big bear and kids were
passing me like
13 14 15 year olds mr miller i'm on your
left
over mr miller like you little
are you kidding me
uh what happened with the utah jazz
situation with quinn smith like where
where where
where are they headed
uh
look i don't know because you've got two
players who
let's face it they don't get along
donovan mitchell
and rudy gobert they don't get along and
i think quinn snyder's voice has been
lost
and he is a great coach he's not a good
coach he is a great coach
um
with new ideas and he's a great
motivator but for whatever reason he
could not get these two guys
on the same page and it's sad because
in today's game of how it's played
in inside and out presence like those
two guys for them not to be on the same
page
i'm wondering who can come in and
correct that
to me one of them has to go because i
keep hearing that coming out of the camp
rudy's saying it's him or me
something has to happen
i wonder why quinn decided to quit
you know what the lakers job was open i
don't know if that's you know
he came up he came out publicly and said
he wasn't going to take the laker job
because of what and how they treated
frank vogel on the way out okay okay so
he came out and said that he had zero
interest in the laker job
yeah i just wonder
like donovan mitchell
where could you see a landing spot for
there there's obviously a lot of teams
that love to have him it's just what do
you give up to get he's under contract
for the next four years he just signed a
big deal yeah same with ruby rudy has i
think three more years on a big deal as
well
look i think you've got to get these
guys in a room
and see if they can figure it out i
don't think it can happen but you gotta
at least try right
uh you played against darvanham right
i did and he was a teammate of mine at
one point in indiana i think he's gonna
be great i think his voice is going to
resonate with the lakers and the lakers
uh
the fan base
it'll be interesting because i listen to
the words of how he spoke
about russell and you've got to approach
it with
respect and not knowing what's going to
happen up until training camp because
they could still end up trading russ
but how he approached
that press conference in mentioning russ
in his vision
and pumping them up that's what you got
to do today he and he's right he is
still one of the best players in the
game
does he have a lot of flaws absolutely
but if you can work around that and you
still have lebron you still have a.d
there's
there's ways where you can make this
work it's going to be a challenge don't
get me wrong
but sometimes you just need a new voice
theodore and i think darwin hands is
going to be great for the lakers are you
gonna text me after tonight's game win
or lose i am i'm texting you tonight
win or lose
and what's the line tonight who's
favorite boston by three and a half
this is
game three is going to be great when
it's 1-1 it's going to be a dog fight
because
i can't wait to text you win or lose i'm
texting you okay i'm just like you take
forever to text me back now i know it's
late on you on you know your enemies
yeah
yeah but
text the brother back in a timely
fashion
thank you raj i appreciate it reginald
aloysius
mutton button we'll take a break uh last
call for phone calls what we learned
what's in store tomorrow reggie of
course is going to take part in the
ranch rally this saturday